tests are always stressful no matter how
old you are this is why some kids
decided that they wouldn't be taking
things too seriously and the results are
hilarious just wait until you see why a
mother received a call from the school
because of a drawing if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you 20 funniest kid test answers
find X mathematics used to be fun when
it was all about numbers additions and
subtractions we knew that we would
simply be using a calculator as
grown-ups anyway but then someone added
letters and ruined everything since that
day one of our favorite school subjects
became much more difficult than what we
expected this is why this kid decided to
take it easy and outsmart the teacher
the question was find X and this kid
didn't think too much about it this is
why he said that it was right there
drawing a circle around the letter
instead of finding the right number we
think that this student deserves a good
grade he did find the letter X after all
what ended in 1896 people say that you
can't know where you're going until you
know where you've been we know that it
is important to understand why tragic
events happened and to make sure that we
learn from it and don't make these
mistakes again but there is no reason
why we would need to know all the dates
to really make a change in history this
teacher asked a ridiculous question what
ended in 1896 there are so many things
that ended in this year that too many
answers were possible but this student
chose the most obvious one just by
looking at the question if there is
something that obviously ended in 1896
it is the year 1895 no one can argue
with that if you want to watch just one
more video the premium is the platform
where you should go get early access to
videos from the things the taco the
trendy the richest and many other great
channels in one place with ad free
browsing click this link to sign up for
free to the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels which one is bigger
we all remember this question from our
mathematics class and it was not one of
the most difficult ones to answer the
greater than and lesser than symbols
were easy to use the smallest side of
the arrow was pointing to the smallest
number things became a little more
complicated with decimal numbers but we
were ready to face this new challenge
unfortunately it's
like this kid thought that he was in
English class and mistook them for Latin
quotation marks quoting the word or
answering the question in mathematics
has never been so easy he just wrote the
word or everywhere this is the proof
that when the answer is too easy to find
there is probably a trick somewhere the
candy bars mathematics could be all
about simple additions and subtractions
but our teachers decided to make it a
little funnier by telling us stories
about characters buying and giving away
things we don't think that it made the
test more interesting in any way but at
least we understood how to use
mathematics in our everyday lives
Bob's problems were no different than
any others bob has 36 candy bars
he eats 29 what does he have now but if
you are the kind of kid who asks
themselves too many questions you would
understand that this little story is
ridiculous if there is one thing that he
can have it is diabetes bob has diabetes
show you're thinking every kid knows
that teachers love to understand how we
solved our problems unfortunately it
forces us all to think the same way even
though there could be many ways to find
the answer it also makes us think too
much when a simple question could have
been way less complicated and as long as
we are right why would anyone care about
how we solve the problem no grown-up
does that when the answer is really easy
to find this is probably why this kid
decided to make fun of the teacher he
was asked show your thinking and instead
of writing a useless equation he decided
to draw himself thinking we think that
this student deserves bonus points for
making his teacher laugh why are their
rings on Saturn for once this is an
interesting question and we will give
you the right answer the rings
originated from a small moon or passing
comets that were torn to shreds by the
planets gravity it formed too close to
Saturn and became rings instead there
are still many questions left unanswered
but this is the best theory that
astronomers came up with and this is
what this student was supposed to write
but he didn't like being serious this is
why this kid decided to try something
funnier instead inspired by his favorite
singer he said that God likes it so he
put a ring on it it seems like the
teacher liked the joke because he
replied that Saturn is not a single lady
cause-and-effect school isn't only about
mathematical equations that you'll never
use in your entire life and grammar
rules to learn by heart sometimes it is
also about understanding what will
happen if you do something this time the
teacher probably wanted their students
to say that Toni will become a better
pianist if he practices the piano 20
minutes every day
but this is not what is happening in the
mind of a bully instead this kid said
that it would make him a big nerd and
you know what there is nothing wrong
with it if being good at something means
that you're a nerd we'll take that as a
compliment the teacher should pay
attention to this little bully we don't
know what he'll be saying to the other
kids in class in which state at school
we learn what a homophone is it is words
that have the same pronunciation but
different meanings or spellings as we
can see this kid is taking a test in
science class but he is probably even
worse in English when we see the mistake
that he made when asked in which state
do the particles show the most movement
he answered California and even made a
mistake in the name of the American
state then when asked in which state to
the particle showed the least movement
he wrote New Jersey making another
mistake in the name we don't know what
makes him think that particles are
slower in this state but this time we
would like to know his thinking where is
the question sometimes we would like to
tell the whole world that we just can't
everyone woke up one day not wanting to
get out of bed and going to school to
take a test if the last thing that could
motivate us to make any efforts we know
that no matter how hard we studied the
teacher is going to ask us only about
the things that we don't understand this
student managed to go to school to take
the test but when he realized that he
couldn't understand the question he knew
that he was not even in the mood to see
it this is why he just decided to white
out the question that he didn't want to
answer we wish that we could do the same
thing in life when our mother asks us to
do chores at home we just can't the
geometric shapes why do we have to learn
anything about geometric shapes knowing
that this thing is called the
parallelogram is useless when you know
that you can call it a rectangle that is
sort of falling on one side it seems
like this student studied harder than us
because he was able to name almost every
shape including the Pentagon and the
rhombus but when he saw this trapezoid
he did what any grown-up would do when
they see a geometric shape that they
don't know he used an example to
describe it the best way he could and
you know what as long as people can
understand you there is nothing wrong
with forgetting the name of a geometric
shape sometimes who do you want to be
every little kid has a hero and wants to
be just like them these role models
inspire them to become someone great
and their story is the proof that
everyone can make their dreams come true
if they work hard Michael Jordan is a
great basketball player that we can use
as an inspiration but it seems like this
child knew nothing about him except
he looks when the teacher asked the kid
how he was going to achieve his dreams
he said that he was going to get bigger
shave his head and be black we hope that
this kid will hear more about Michael
Jordan's story if he wants to have what
it takes to become a professional
athlete problems and solutions
understanding a trigonometric circle and
learning by heart all the chemical
elements of the periodic table is not
something that you will have to remember
when you grow up unless you want to
study science but school is also about
learning real-life problems and finding
solutions on your own a teacher asked
their young students what they would do
if they fell on the playground and
scratch their knee and one of the
students was tougher than the other kids
he simply said that he would get up and
deal with it someone should tell him
about infections because no matter how
cool he looks when he gets back up it
won't stop bacteria from infecting him
the walrus as long as we understand
basic mathematics most of us won't
really need most of the things that we
learn in class but this kid knows what's
important saving the planet and it seems
like it was the right time to do it when
he was in class
he wasn't even done writing numbers in
his book when he decided to draw a
walrus over it instead he explained that
the walrus has lost his home due to
global warming and chose to reside in
his math book he then apologized for any
inconvenience caused on his behalf this
kid isn't wrong after all learning
algebra will be useless for most of us
if there is no life on earth anymore in
the following years petting the dog in
elementary school we all had to fill the
blanks to complete a sentence the
sentences were usually really simple
like the man can run or Sophie ate a
cookie but a teacher wrote something a
little more inappropriate in a test most
children simply completed the sentence
without asking any questions because
they trust their teacher but this kid
wouldn't let this happen there was a
picture of a man hitting a dog with a
newspaper and the student was shocked to
see that this is why instead of writing
what he saw he wrote what he wanted to
see the man pet the dog he also had a
little lesson to teach his class you
should not hit dog's name six animals
this question seems to be really simple
but we have to admit that we would have
a hard time answering it named six
animals which live specifically in the
Arctic our first guess would be penguins
but many of us would be surprised to
know that they live on the Antarctic
coastline on the other side of the world
this kid was smarter than us and knew
that polar bears and seals live in the
Arctic but he didn't remember the name
of any other animal so he added one
polar bear and two
nope three other seals for a total of
six this kid might be good in
mathematics but we don't think that his
science teacher is really impressed is
Steve speeding every kid who ever went
to school ask themselves the question
what is this for most of the things we
learn in high school will never be
useful during the rest of our lives and
it seems like our teachers just want to
make us suffer from all these equations
we should learn about cooking finances
and laws instead but our teachers seem
to think that some things are more
important this time they told the story
of Steve who was driving a car they said
that he was travelling at 60 feet per
second when the limit was 40 miles per
hour and asked if he was speeding it
might look like something that we need
to know in our everyday lives as
grown-ups but the right thing to do is
much simpler just look at the
speedometer the risk this is one of the
most famous questions that many teachers
have been asked in philosophy class and
there is one surprising way to answer
this many people would think about
reading books on the subject quoting the
most important philosopher in history
and writing three pages on this topic
but there is only one way to really know
what risk is and it is to experience it
this is why the best answer to this
question is simply this we clearly
understand why this student got a point
for his answer many of us would have
never thought about this the giraffe
after seeing so many kids who don't know
the right answer to a question many of
us would like to give up tests are
stressful and we feel like we just
forced too much information into our
brains only to throw it up on a piece of
paper and never remember it again this
is why we hope that our teachers
understand that sometimes we have much
more important things to care about and
we can't study for 25 hours every day
but instead of complaining this student
had another idea to get a better grade
he drew a picture of a funny giraffe and
wrote please note if I made any mistakes
in this test perhaps this picture of a
giraffe will convince you otherwise and
guess what the teacher gave him a bonus
point on this test we think that we'll
be trying this one to describe school
most of the kids on this list shared the
same feeling about school if there is
one thing that we all love it is a lunch
break but many of those who cannot sit
with their friends or the popular kids
can't wait for the break to be over we
have to admit that school isn't for
everyone so when the teacher asked a kid
to describe the school in one word he
gave the perfect answer hell when I grow
up this one deserves an explanation so
we'll show it right now when a teacher
asked a student what she wanted to be
when
grows up this girl drew a picture of her
mother on a stage even though there is
nothing wrong with this job this is not
something a child should wish to do at
such a young age this is why the mother
had to explain this drawing she worked
at Home Depot and during the blizzard
there was only one shovel left people
were fighting over who would get it and
offering money it is not a pole but a
shovel and we bet that this mother will
pay more attention to what her daughter
is drawing next time did you answer
anything funny during a test when you
were at school don't be shy to tell us
what it was in the comment section below
and that's it for 20 funniest kid test
answers for more stories like this don't
forget to watch 10 toys that weren't
supposed to be for kids thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]